hi everybody I'm really hoping I'm next
my name is Emeka la la I'm the editor in
residence at the d.school at Stanford
University Thank You Justin I came from
the Washington Post I'm currently taking
a year off from there where I was the
founding editor of innovations and
everybody keep calm because I'm gonna do
the wait what part I I'm doing a talk on
fear and I am quite frankly terrified I
had no time to prepare this I didn't
make the slides so we're gonna see how
it goes welcome home I am from
Washington DC this is where I live I
have lived here for well over eight to
ten years depending on how you want to
count it went to college this is work I
worked at The Washington Post The
Washington Post was my home it was where
I did all of the wonderful things that I
love to do which was writing producing
basically just getting my thoughts out I
had a home there in terms of being able
to get a corner of one of the most
prestigious publications in the world
and I wouldn't replace for anything then
I met Willy Wonka it's such a shame the
fonts don't work on these slides that's
okay that's just in feral if you don't
know Justin he's the director of
fellowships at the d.school
and he gave me a golden ticket to go to
California and to basically figure out
what design thinking is and this is
Wonderland this is where I live and work
now this is the d.school
it is a magical place full of red
couches and whiteboards and so so much
more if you've ever been there there's a
lot more to it than what you see um
trust me I know okay who does that who
goes all the way across the country
gives up a home gives up a life gives up
a dream career I mean I was an editor at
the post before I was 30 who leaves that
I do you would too if you had the
opportunity in you met this amazing guy
it was probably the best decision I ever
made it also helps me go to paradise
anybody seen a rainbow on Stanford
campus I've seen one twice that's two
times more than I've seen in Washington
DC so this place you draw you ride up
you don't drive up you ride up every day
on your bicycle which I eventually
learned to do design thinking in 15
seconds how many of you are familiar
with design thinking go go go go yes you
start with your user empathize you then
define your problem then you brains from
around that problem you prototype it and
then you test it your prototype it as
cheaply as possible by the way cuz the
three million dollar prototype gets you
nowhere so how I list learn Design
Thinking they critique everything I know
because I did they mock the pipe
cleaners in the duct tape I know because
I did and they wash for instance
for three months I know because I did
and then we're waiting and we're waiting
because we're watching and we freaked
out because you realize that this field
needs design thinking more than just
about anything else and you have no idea
what you're doing
I really have it for the last nine
months but now I'm in month ten so
clearly I do this journalism really
needs the stuff I've just had my life
changed but in having my life changed I
also realized that fear is a very real
thing it is something that you have to
contend with it is something that you
have to deal with and it is a very large
driver in our day-to-day lives
I made my assignments I did my work on
fear so without further ado here are
three lessons on mastering fear from a
newly-minted design thinker I don't
think that quite made it but that's okay
so I'm newly minted I've only been doing
this for ten months so bear with me I
also didn't really prepare as I
mentioned some freaking out a little bit
fear yeah here's my champion this is
rule number one find a champion find
somebody who's gonna stand up for you
find somebody who's learning how to
stand up for themselves
this woman is named Ann Gibbon she's a
fellow at the d.school she recently
graduated this is her first year as a
civilian after 14 years serving in the
military she graduated from the Naval
Academy she's a big fan of pink pants so
I would say that if you do find your
champion the disclaimer is your champion
should come with 14 years of military
experience and a healthy collection of
jewel-tone pants I lived with Ann Gibbon
she is my roommate she works out with me
is the reason I lost 10 pounds it is why
I look so fabulous today take it all out
on a white board this is rule number two
figure it out figure all of it out go to
a white board make mistakes white boards
are easily erased they are easily
changed just go about it do it it
doesn't matter go to places where you
realize that failure is not only an
option instant inevitability and when it
comes to white boards it is inevitable
for me this is a photo of a massive
drawing that I did while I was at the
d.school
um I was taking bootcamp I literally
took over a full wall of white board to
create this illustration I don't draw I
write let me just be clear about one
thing there so I did that I also started
a new blog called the white board the
white board is a project of the d.school
fellows it is where I love to write and
figure out how to learn design thinking
and how nine amazing individuals
including and learn Design Thinking it
brought it back to amazing organizations
also we should just shut up
and listen okay that is a great thing to
do because when you were talking to
people and you're actually doing the
work of design thinking you should take
a minute and really be quiet just listen
to the person and ask why also helps if
you can find a family that is capable of
doing this the d.school we do crazy
things we do improv we do just about
everything that you can possibly imagine
I'm a theater major I'm an international
relations major coming out of college I
did journalism but now I realize this
place part too so if you're ever scared
and it's too much please come and find
me I'll be here for you with a sharpie
and some posters thank you
[Applause]